[Musik]
die idee zu der geschichte die kamen mir
eigentlich so mitte letzten jahres
da hab ich ne doku gesehen überzeugen
und da ist mir bewusst geworden dass ich
eigentlich noch nie so wirklich
ausführliche und lange gespräche mit
menschen geführt hat die den zweiten
weltkrieg erlebt haben oder die schlimme
sachen im zweiten weltkrieg erlebt haben
denn meine großeltern die leben leider
schon nicht mehr meine omas habe ich
noch erlebt aber die wollten auch nie
über die zeit reden
also haben so bei mir der wunsch auf
dass ich das gerne mal machen würde denn
man muss man ehrlich sein die menschen
die diese zeit bewusst erlebt haben die
werden immer weniger also da gibt es
nicht mehr so viele die man interviewen
könnte und dann bin ich auf die suche
gegangen nach einem kollegen der das mit
mir zusammen machen möchte und da ist
mir natürlich mein kollege lorenz
eingefallen der experte auf dem
kriegsgebiet ist sage ich mal genau und
so bin ich zu dir gekommen bei mir ist
es ein bisschen anders ich habe mich
komischerweise wie das schicksal so will
schon als kleiner junge habe ich die
kriegsliteratur verschlungen
weil es mich einfach so interessiert hat
und umso mehr weil natürlich davon
begeistert als die karte auf mich zukam
und gesagt hat wollen wir das machen da
war ich natürlich sofort dabei was wir
dann getan haben war dass wir wirklich
alle möglichen hebel in bewegung gesetzt
haben um zu sehen wo bekommen wir noch
leute her die mit uns sprechen denn es
ist jetzt 75 jahre her dass der zweite
weltkrieg zu ende gegangen ist und das
lässt sich leicht ausrechnen 75 plus
naja mindestens 580 da ist schon jeder
zweite jede zweite frau jeder zweite
mann ist das schon gestorben in dem
alter wie viele leute bekommen wir da
überhaupt noch zusammen die bereit sind
mit uns zu sprechen und uns ihre
geschichte zu erzählen
wir haben dann wirklich mit allen
möglichen leuten versucht kontakt
aufzunehmen über bekannte über unsere
social media kanäle und auch über
stiftungen über museen alles mögliche
was ging und das feedback das war
wirklich überwältigend und dann nach dem
mittagessen hat meine mutter
als beide zu sich geholt und hat uns
gesagt also das attentat auf den führer
das war der partie wir hatten eigentlich
noch geplant noch mindestens zwei
zeitzeugen mehr in die serie mit herein
zu nehmen und dann kam corona und wir
durften gar nicht mehr reisen die
älteren leute gehören natürlich auch zur
hochrisikogruppe das heißt schon unsere
letzte zeitzeuge in die wir interviewt
haben die else becker
das war schon ganz kurz vor dem showdown
hier bei uns da haben wir uns aber
trotzdem entschieden noch nach london zu
fliegen
ganz kurz vorher die woche drauf war mir
glaube ich schon im home office oder die
woche ja genau also es waren noch 23
tage ich glaube sogar dass war die
letzte faz reise vor vor dem schotter
und die wir gemacht haben
also natürlich auch in abstimmung mit
der else becker wir haben wir haben
lange überlegt und auch mit überlegt
können wir das risiko noch eingehen
zu ihr zu reisen und am ende des tages
waren wir glaube ich alle drei sehr froh
dass wir das noch gemacht haben und
möglicherweise da hat es auch keine
spätfolgen hab ich ja vorgestern noch
mit else becker telefoniert es geht ihr
gut sie geht raus vor die tür auch noch
nach wie vor auf kleine spaziergänge
wird versorgt von ihrem sohn
das war eigentlich für uns das
wichtigste dass wir da nicht für den
preis einer guten geschichte
irgendwelche menschen gefährden und
deshalb gottlob auch geklappt
und zwar ist wichtig dass wir sowohl
frauen als auch männer haben über den
krieg erzählen nicht nur soldaten und
auch menschen verschiedenen alters die
kinder die leute die an der heimatfront
waren die leute die gekämpft haben
natürlich auch ein holocaust opfer und
diese facette mit reinzubringen
flüchtlinge hätten wir gern auch mit
drin gehabt diese diese facette ist ja
leider aufgrund der reisebeschränkungen
dann rausgefallen ebenso wie die facette
einer frau die daheim gearbeitet hat
aber die übrigen haben wir halt drin wir
haben wir haben das kriegskind das
verschleppt wurde mit mit graf
stauffenberg wir haben das auschwitz
kind das gerettet wurde
wir haben einen der auf einem schiff
quasi dem ertrinken tod entronnen ist
mit horst schön und wir haben dann
schließlich noch mit willibald riedel
erstmal einen sehr alten mann mit 100
jahren und dann halt jemanden der
wirklich den gesamten krieg über an der
ost form von 41 bis 50 miterlebt hat und
das ist eine eine eine mischung von der
man natürlich nicht sagen kann dass es
alle facetten abdeckt ist das ist
niemals möglich aber wo man wirklich
einen einen sehr breiten eindruck
bekommt was für unterschiedliche
erlebnisse und auch schicksale die
menschen in dieser zeit erlebt haben
die im moment wurde das schiff sich
drehte und unterging war das ein riesen
schneider weit beiden weit zu hören war
von den menschen dort an bord ja
den start habe ich immer noch hin
was mich unglaublich beeindruckt hat
gerade bei horst schön das war diese
helmut schmidt perspektive diese
beurteilung unserer probleme mit denen
wir heute konfrontiert sind denn die
haben unfassbares leid erlebt der zweite
weltkrieg ist bei aller würdigung dessen
mit dem wir heute uns auseinandersetzen
müssen ja noch eine ganz andere nummer
gewesen mit dutzenden von millionen
toten
und von denen die einschätzung zu
bekommen wie sie das sehen dass das hat
mir unheimlich viel gegeben und das war
auch spannend zu sehen wie
unterschiedlich die leute das sehen ja
der eine sehr pessimistisch ist schön
wie die bald riedel der totale optimist
und die anderen beiden hinten so
dazwischen wie unsere ostpreußen
flüchtlinge ins mecklenburgische oder
sagen wir mal in den westen damals kam
da war die solidarität der deutschen
untereinander nicht beispielhaft
also mich hat das gespräch mit else
becker besonders berührt vielleicht auch
weil ich eine tochter habe die gerade in
dem alter ist in dem else damals war als
sie nach auschwitz gekommen ist und
diese vorstellung was dieses kleine
mädchen damals erlebt hat und das so
intensiv zuhören und sie hat es wirklich
sie hat es ja selber auch sehr bewegt
also sie hat während des gesprächs
angefangen zu weinen so hüther diese
ganzen kleinen demütigungen die die
menschen damals erlebt haben
das fand ich unheimlich bewegend und
berührend das hat mich sehr sehr gepackt
und auch nach dem gespräch war bei uns
beiden war lorenz und mir glaube ich
zwei stunden haben wir kaum miteinander
geredet
auf dem heimflug weil wir beide wirklich
sehr erschüttert waren von dieser
begegnung ich muss sagen man möchte
einfach danach noch mal sagen man darf
diese zeit nie vergessen und es wird
einem noch mal bewusst wie gut es uns
geht schon uns dass wir selbst keinen
krieg erlebt haben und unseren kindern
wie behütet die aufwachsen
das ist keine selbstverständlichkeit
deswegen bin ich der ansicht es ist toll
dass wir mit diesen mit dieser serie
noch mal zeigen man darf diese zeit
einfach nicht vergessen wir sind da
draußen wesen tom mit dem dispo durch
die rechtspopulisten so schlimmes erlebt
wie im zweiten weltkrieg
egal ob es in welcher stelle er gekämpft
hatte gelebt hat es ist furchtbar
gewesen
also mir persönlich hat dieses projekt
tatsächlich viel gegeben und mein
ursprünglicher wunsch hat sich damit
erfüllt das ich da ganz tollen menschen
begegnet bin und ich hätte tatsächlich
gerne noch mehrere dieser interviews
geführt und wir haben schon überlegt ob
wir das nicht vielleicht in zukunft auch
noch machen wollen mein fazit ist dass
der schwerste teil jetzt noch bevorsteht
den leuten abzusagen die sich bereit
erklärt haben mit uns zu sprechen und
ich neige ähnlich wie kati dazu zu sagen
ich halte oder wir halten die zahl
dieser absagen relativ gering und
schauen mit wem wir auch nach der
kapitulation überlegung noch zusammen
kommen um mit den leuten zu sprechen
werk sind es diese geschichten in jedem
fall
und für diejenigen von ihnen die
interesse haben sich alle vier teile
noch einmal anzuschauen
sie sind und bleiben natürlich im netz
verfügbar unter fax punkt mit geschichte
feedback wie es ihnen wie es euch
gefallen hat freuen wir uns sehr darüber
und vielleicht ist es für uns auch noch
weitere motivation in die richtung
weiter zu machen
[Musik]